i'm so mad that they didn't take that
incredible opportunity of like yeah like
we have this this character who can
change faces
you know and also like and then it it
gives jamie a better ending than he had
and cersei just got crushed by rocks and
just and arya just
sailed away like
to kokomo or wherever and i'm just
i'm unhappy
[Music]
now tom i know you're not into geek
stuff
um
so i know you're at a bit of a
disadvantage here what i mean in your
research when i asked you about this
what did you find about game of thrones
that you kind of thought might be
interesting to talk about with this
topic you know i got to tell you man i i
i
tried to read into this and i i know we
have fun right we like we like a good
laugh we tried whatever this show is
called but
i genuinely know nothing about game of
thrones i am
like everybody's it's like it's like
that famous quote from the show goes i
know nothing just like that character
jack frost
nailed it
with all of the like confusingly spelled
names and stuff i can imagine even just
trying to read a bunch of theories if
you're not familiar it feels like
reading a foreign language you know
there's a lot going on and i'm i'm
really not familiar so i think hey but
any time that we talk about this show
like i'm always fascinated to hear you
especially like nina knows so much about
it i i really don't so
i would i would love a better
introduction into this world like
that conduit like and if i could just
like ask clarifying questions as we go i
i feel like you can i i would love i
would love to but i am curious brian you
have watched the show i watched the
whole series yeah i read all the books
yes but when it come but i one thing i
never did was go on reddit never i had
friends who would like who would text me
and they're like oh my god on reddit
they said this and i'm like i literally
do not care i couldn't care less about
what reddit says yeah there's like all
these these theories that are like j
plus v equals p 90 x or whatever i don't
know what it is like right isn't that
like my name
yeah so you already know what i'm
talking about it's nonsense
that was a theory that came that was
true
well but what is the theory what even is
it they were doing like numerology stuff
what was going on it was the kabbalah r
plus l equals j and it was basically the
jon snow is not ned stark's bastard but
he was the right he was the son of a
prince and a noble woman which meant he
was the heir to the iron throne the
whole time and so that one part for
rhaegar l for leanna
j for jon snow
that's what that meant yep got the tldr
version of it but yeah that well that
theory had been floating around since
the first book came out like a billion
years ago
and then the show did eventually confirm
it and then that was at that point the
show was still pretty okay
yeah that was like the end of season six
or seven and it was like fine
yeah right so yeah
to prepare for this uh for this
conversation
i asked you to hook us up with some
theories and i took a look at some of
the theories that were out there that i
thought were were uh interesting that i
could kind of wrap my head around like
okay this is a theory that is
that makes sense to me that i have some
kind of idea for but also is really
stupid and and
you know i i don't know okay so one of
the ones that i saw was um uh this the
theory that the white walkers would come
back before the end of the last episode
that was a theory that some people
floated because they were like well it
can't be over this fast and this evening
that they just storytelling can't be
this bad and then right like like you
build up this ultimate threat in this
over the course of yeah these 10 years
yeah and then it's this bad spider yeah
a pre-teen with a knife
uh stabbing yeah stabbing a monster who
right and and there was this whole like
i'm gonna bring up benny off and weiss
again uh they they were like oh aria's
the person you least expect to kill the
night king and it's like yeah because it
doesn't make any narrative sense like i
love that moment as much as anyone else
because it's a triumphant cool moment
but also like she has no connection to
this character she's had nothing to do
with their storyline it's dumb and
narratively it's unsatisfying
right yeah so the idea was that by the
end of the last episode like it would be
like oh you thought that you were done
with this you thought there was an easy
solution to this you think that this
throne thing matters it doesn't yeah the
white walkers are still coming from and
actually it would have been a pretty
baller ending to the show if the last
shot circled all the way back to the
pilot and it was like there's a white
walker in the woods again and they're
just back now that would have been
pretty awesome that would have been a
really cool like final button on that
series of like oh yeah they're just
still out there you guys didn't do
anything because the theme the theme of
the show is that all of these people are
like trying to screw each other over to
get this throne but ultimately it
doesn't matter there's this huge threat
there's a big problem like theme
thematically that's what matters the
most yeah so yeah the way that it ended
was just kind of like oh no but actually
the throne does really matter and just
you know whoever right
and you know and then they also
destroyed the throne in the finale
because dragons understand symbolism
apparently yes this is a very literal
illiterate dragon
so tom just just to let you know in the
finale when uh
daenerys dies
her dragon comes down it looks like
she's murdered yeah
jon snow who killed her he's like how
about i torch this throne instead and
then that's what made my mother crazy
yeah the dragon totally got
the symbol is so stupid it was pretty
lame um it's really really dumb
again very new to this who should have
killed the night king that's the that's
the snowmobilizer right that's just
john
it's a boring choice but it's the
correct choice he's the only one of the
only characters who ever killed a white
walker before besides sam and sam kind
of did it by accident because that's
sam's whole deal john did it in actual
battle multiple times um and he had the
most connection to the night king
like every character
yes he's the character who has faced off
against the night king over and over and
over again it's like if in harry potter
like harry didn't kill voldemort but
like like ginny did and you'd be like
why she has no
well she'd even have a like
with him
luna lovegood killed voldemort you'd be
like that doesn't make any sense why
would luna do it it's set up and payoff
right like in the in the movie willow
willow is a movie i enjoy a lot and it
has one of my favorite setups and
payoffs in all of storytelling which is
that in the beginning willow is this
little guy who's trying to do magic and
he wants to be a a powerful wizard and
he does this disappearing pig trick and
it doesn't go right
disappearing pig trick doesn't go right
but he's going to set off on this
adventure to bring the baby back blah
blah blah blah and at the end he faces
off against the bad morta i think is the
sorceresses okay and he's got the baby
that she's after this baby that she's
trying to kill for this prophecy so it
won't come true
and he
he makes her go away and she thinks that
it's magic that she can't figure out and
then something happens and she dies blah
blah blah and then at the end you go oh
willow what did you do with the baby and
he goes it was my old disappearing pig
trick like the thing from the beginning
yeah yeah yeah set up right or what do
you have
i'm not gonna spoil the entirety of
knives out even though that movie is
kind of old you know old at this point
but like there is a thing at the
beginning of the movie that tells you
the ending of the movie in the first
five to 10 minutes and it's awesome it's
such a good payoff at the end you're
like oh my god like it blows your mind
and set up yeah if if arya had some
greater connection
to this and they tried to retcon it with
melisandre being like you're gonna kill
a blue-eyed person and it's like that
doesn't it's so stupid that doesn't make
any sense like you're just shoehorning
in a thing
yeah no and they're running in an
unrelated thing yeah we're not talking
about theories anymore now we're just
yelling at you yes now we're just
yelling you're right um
but uh
speaking to what you were you were
saying like narratively
i feel like part of what made knives out
uh really charming like what a lot of
people loved about it was that it
doesn't
pull a twist ending on you like it's
it's a story that makes sense
they don't they don't pull a giant twist
in the third act where it turns out that
it was actually like
anna delarmos was the one that killed it
like right it's not that
it
but i feel like a lot of stories right
now are
especially the last like 10 years or so
are built specifically on the idea that
there has to be this giant twist and it
can't be what anybody is expecting right
right and that's like that that's what
happened with the aria thing to be
honest is they were like it can't be jon
snow it's too obvious when like again
that would have been the correct payoff
and that's why people thought
yeah sorry no no and i was
i was looking up just because i need to
refresh myself in some of the series
it's been a couple years and i found a a
vulture article written by a writer
named alicia lutz uh from right before
the uh uh finale aired and she was like
what if bran became king that would be
stupid and i was like oh god like that's
literally what happens and it's the
dumbest because again that's trying to
subvert expectations when it's like
it's the person you least expect but
that but the justification for it in the
show just makes
no because it all goes back to game of
thrones was so successful and this is
george r martin's doing in cutting off
ned stark's head is the best subversion
of expectations in like
recent fantasy history
and but it also sets off a massive war
that takes up most of the rest of the
story it's not just like haha we did for
shock value it serves as a serious
narrative purpose right nothing that
benny often weiss decided
did that um but yeah i i have a few
theories i want to i want to touch on if
that's okay or unless you have another
one brian i just wanted to wrap up what
i was going to say yeah that's why
people thought the white walkers were
going to come back yeah because it was
like
yeah right because again the setup and
the setup is that the first thing we see
in this series are the white walkers and
then to end it with while they're gone
now
right
doesn't work so that was that was the
one theory that i thought was was really
good but it didn't pan out and that's a
shame the other theory that i read about
that i thought was interesting was that
um apparently dragonglass was theorized
to be dragon poop
i never saw that one
but it wasn't
it wasn't out that way no dragonglass
tom is the is the material that you can
use to kill a
walker internet someone on the internet
someone
white
theorized that um it was actually dragon
poop but
they didn't they didn't go all in on
these they didn't go
so that was another theory that was
pretty interesting that didn't pan out
but anyway nina you wanted to say
something no it's i'm fascinated by the
dragon
that's it that's literally the whole
theory
what did dragon glass wind up being it's
just just just dragon glass it's just
it's a thing that exists okay
it's kind of like vibranium you know you
just you you hear about it and you let
it go
yeah yeah
you're like sure that exists so nina
what are the theories that you wanted to
talk about yeah i had two that i really
wanted to happen well one that i really
wanted to happen and one that i was like
this would have been interesting but it
didn't make a whole lot of sense so i'll
start with the one that didn't make a
whole lot of sense uh there was a
long-running
theory left over from the books that
kind of makes a little more sense in the
books that people did carry into the
show that tyrion lannister played by
peter dinklage was actually a targaryen
and that he was the love child yes he
was the love child of a
maybe non-consensual affair between
uh daenerys father i believe eris and
um uh
uh tywin lannister's wife
and
it would have explained a lot of like
tywin constantly is like you're no son
of mine and you know he doesn't in the
books i think he doesn't really look
like his siblings which is also unfair
because they're literally twins um but
in the books he has like i think in the
books he's supposed to have purple eyes
right which is kind of a symbol of
targaryens and his hair is much blonder
and obviously a lot of that changed when
they when they cast when they perfectly
cast peter dinklage to play him um but i
thought they were gonna do that at one
point because when he does meet the
dragons they don't immediately murder
him and i was like hmm like yeah he's
actually interacting with them like
calmly and they're responding to him can
they say that's the second bloodline and
it was like a really cool setup and then
uh
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing also nothing um but the one that
i'm most upset that did not pay off is
this is another one that comes from the
books that it it could have easily fit
into the show involving three characters
that all got really lackluster endings
so
in the books and we saw this in the tv
show in a cold open um that was at the
beginning of either season four or five
forgive me for not remembering internet
where a young cersei visits a witch in
the woods who tells her that she will
have maggie the frog thank you and she
tells her she will she will marry the
prince or she will marry the king and
that she will have uh three children and
they will all
uh wear crowns and they will all wear
shrouds so she will have three
you know royal children who will all die
and there is another part of that
prophecy that she that cersei will be
killed by the valonqar which means
little brother and they don't really
deal with that in the show
um but valonqar
it means little sibling i guess if you
want to be really really literal and the
really cool twist about that is that she
assumes it's tyrion who is your younger
brother and that's that's kind of the
unsaid reason why she really hates
tyrion
but it but jamie is like two seconds
younger than her so there was a long
simmering theory that jamie would kill
cersei and i was dying for arya to kill
jamie steal his face and kill cersei i
was dying it would have been awesome
that would have been so cool i was like
please do that would have been a good
setup because it would have been a great
setup yeah right it would have been
amazing and like i am so mad that they
didn't take that incredible opportunity
of like yeah like we have this this
character who can change faces
you know and also like and then it it
gives jamie a better ending than he had
and cersei just got crushed by rocks and
just and arya just sailed away like
to kokomo or whatever and i'm just
i'm unhappy
i'm unhappy because that was that was
right there for for the show runners to
take and they just and they could have
done it at the last second anyway right
they could have done it they could have
done it in the final they could have
waited till the finale and they could
have done it they could have done it
right there
he even went there he went there and
they could have just done it but they
didn't yeah no and that's the fan theory
i'm like most disappointed about because
that was that's so cool imagine how
satisfying it would have been to see
arya peel jamie's face off like stand
over cersei that was the last name on
her list yeah she would never finished
yeah
again that's another great setup and
another great payoff that could have
happened or it could have even just been
jamie himself that also could have i
honestly would have been satisfied with
that because that would have completed
jamie's redemption arc instead of
undoing his redemption arc but i would
have loved to see
to the face come off and it's arya and
she's achieved what she wanted to
achieve that would have been that would
have been perfect but uh that is not
what we got
wow there's that
i think this was a great conversation
about game of thrones but clearly tom
does not because he left
all right
tom left the chat i repeat of these
theories and also to tom
oh well
but hopefully everyone else watching
stayed till the end yeah
yeah like tom
[Music]
[Laughter]
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe and leave a nice comment so
you don't make us cry